okay so I was initially cautious but
optimistic about what awaited me past
the soul society and so far it's better
than anything that I've come across in
this story
Soul Society or otherwise it's got wacky
characters interesting plot developments
believable reasons to drag previously
established characters back into The
Fray and it has some of the best designs
in the series so far it's just really
fun and I can't believe where I am with
this series now 240 chapters in and I
genuinely think bleach is awesome so it
begs the question what the hell is up
with the differences between the anime
adaptation and the original manga 10
years ago my first experience with
bleach took place and it really didn't
connect with me then I found characters
annoying and for one reason or another
just ended up dropping the series
entirely however now after having read
the Manga characters like Orihime Khan
and as I'm realizing more and more
through this Arc ichigo's father are all
far more complicated compelling and
Light likeable then the anime itself led
me to believe and I find this personally
strange because this seems to be
something that splits the fandom of
bleach as a whole pun not intended in
other words there are those that agree
with this positive manga sentiment 100
and there are those that don't seem to
be bothered by these differences and
love what the anime uniquely offers I'm
not suggesting either or wrong here but
I guess it goes to show how massive the
difference an experience can be between
two groups with slight preferential
differences making bleach one of the
most pronounced cases of this idea come
across in my journey in the anime I
found the father to be kinda creepy and
massively irritating but in the manga
he's around far less thus making his
random physical intrusions much more
novel than annoying and the same can be
said for Khan however Orihime was
another story she was a character I
pigeonholed as a one note fan service
type character with little to no
substance beyond what she offered on the
surface through gag humor however now
after having read the Manga she is on
ironically my second favorite character
in this story particularly after having
read this week's material with her
struggling to reconcile her self-worth
and ability as it applies to those she
cares about so I guess what I'm trying
to say is if you haven't had a good
experience watching bleach's anime then
try out the manga it worked for me and
if the manga didn't tickle your fancy
then maybe the anime is for you because
personally I am just blown away by how
different an experienced the manga has
delivered me no more am I waiting to be
let down by this story now I am thrilled
to keep reading and to see what more Mr
Kubo has to offer me and it makes me
wonder also if he had any issues with
the way the anime handled his characters
personally anyways without further Ado
let's dive into the first Invasion and
my thoughts on this Arc so far
[Music]
foreign
okay so from the outset we know I loved
my read through of this week's material
however I went into it feeling a certain
level of trepidation following the
conclusion to the soul Society I
questioned whether or not Cuba would be
able to in a satisfying fashion leave
enough unanswered to interest and excite
me for the next Arc to utilize certainly
there's the unanswered Terror
surrounding Eisen and all that he
represents as a threat to the story
however that would be enough to grip me
as a reader personally we never launched
into the soul Society to bring security
and safety to that world or even our own
it was instead all driven by the
interpersonal relationships long since
established from the beginning of the
story and that was more than enough for
me it's sort of what the heartbeat of
bleach has been ichigo's relationships
with his friends and allies why did we
travel into the soul Society to protect
a dear friend we had justifiably grown
attached to over the course of the story
and once we achieved that there was a
wonderful sense of catharsis that
flooded forth from the pages knowing
that Ichigo and his Pals had traveled to
Helen Back and succeeded in their
mission to set their friend free this is
why in the end when Rukia decided to
stay behind it felt reasonable and final
she had served her purpose in the story
it felt and so this seemed like the
perfect ending for her and indeed the
dynamic that drove the story forward
from the beginning and make no mistake
this is what drove the story not Eisen
not the looming threat of something
dogmatic and terrifying that sort of
incidental what gets the readers into
the position to enjoy these Titanic
battles between the likes of Luchi and
Luffy Goku and Frieza are Naruto and
Sasuke are the friendships that acted as
the backbone behind their reasoning
being there whether it be Naruto's
Devotion to saving a friend from himself
Luffy's promise to Grant Robbins wish to
live or the heroes of Earth in Dragon
Ball traveling to the void unknown in
search of a way to bring their lost
comrades back to life every single one
of these iconic battles manifested first
and foremost because of an emotional
connection or deeper reasoning Beyond
wanting to bring just to a particular
group of people we aren't too familiar
with in other words fighting wasn't
enough and fighting on its own isn't
enough for me either in the same way
Frieza wasn't enough of a reason to
bring us to Namek Eisen isn't enough on
his own to bring us back into conflict
unless there's an emotional component so
what do they think of how this Arc
kicked things off well I really really
liked it and it might be the best part
of the series so far in my book too
setting the scene as I mentioned Soul
Society was fun and I assume great for
the time and to this day it Still
Remains for me a solid piece of
Storytelling it had a few hiccups here
and there I would have liked a bit more
necessary secondary character
involvement and I would have liked that
the twist ending with Eisen be a bit
more satisfying but outside of that the
arc itself deals with some really
interesting plot points though some
interesting character exploration for
the likes of Ichigo and sets the bar
fairly high for the series in terms of
action it's a competent story beginning
to end and while I didn't notice any
major issues with the soul society's
introductory sequence either I also
wasn't as excited to read through it
mostly because I sort of had an idea as
to where it would otherwise go competent
as it was it was still a very
traditional and conventional Shonen
story packed with all the trappings you
might expect from the genre again not a
bad thing and I did enjoy it but
something I've learned that I can rely
on their anchor Arc to do consistently
is surprise me with its direction and
application of existing characters
remaining true to the foundation set
upon prior arcs all the while managing
to string me along with a host of
choices I both found surprising and
captivating despite concluding and
resolving the main emotional through
Lane of the previous Arc carried over
into this one are two very compelling
plot lines we'll reduce grappling with
his own lack of power and each go being
both figuratively and literally consumed
by his two contrasting characters with
two contrasting problems having
established both of these worries and
stressors in the prior Arc having
delivered the required closure in the
prior Arc also now we get to experience
and explore the ramifications of these
two lines of narrative two lines of
narrative that complement each other
rather brilliantly might I add the first
set piece or conflict that takes place
in this Arc occurs when three different
entities attack three different
characters though right now I'd like to
discuss Ichigo and uriu's respective
conflicts first and let me tell you
these are near perfect and provide by
far the best intro and hook I've
received so far from this story as a
reader
so there's this new character in town
called Shinji and he looks all sorts of
screwed up and concerning ichigo's fight
Shinji represents an easy solution to a
terrifying problem that seems to be
plaguing Ichigo the fear of losing
himself to the darkness inside of him
with every passing day each passing
fight he feels his grip on the hilt of
his sword loosening more and more
concerned that one day the powerful
entity that dwells within him we saw
last time might take control for good
speaking to the fear that I explored
last time Ichigo is terrified that this
darker Force inside of him is something
he needs to always fight against at
every possible moment an exhausting
effort for sure one that makes what
Shinji is offering all the more alluring
with him claiming that Ichigo is
fighting against his inherent nature
that his true nature is rejecting his
decision to be a soul Reaper and that he
should join him and become something
that he calls a wizard which just sounds
like a German pronouncing the word
wizard and after a quick Google I now
realize that it's called weizard by
mistake
you think your current earbuds are
powerful well think again raycon's
everyday earbuds just graduated from the
soul society and they look feel and
sound better than ever and just like a
zenpakuto these raycons come in a
variety of new forms like this fancy
blue one but they also have a focus on
the form of your ear thanks to their
optimized gel tips you can go berserk
like in patchy or bouncy like Orihime
and these will not budge they've even
got you covered for hours too thanks to
eight hours of play time and 32 hours of
battery life that's like 8 hours of
Canon and 32 hours of Filler episodes
It's amazing they're super customizable
too for example you can swap between
three sound profiles to really tailor
the sound to your preference pure sound
for pristine vocals and podcasts balance
sound for a one size fits-all approach
across many genres or just go wild with
a full bass sound to really amplify
bleach's legendary soundtrack you can
also pick noise isolation or awareness
mode to decide whether you want to be
totally immersed or keep track of what's
going on around you it's as simple as
holding the left and right earbud
respectively for three seconds to cycle
through these modes they really are
pristine and priced perfectly you get
all this fantastic audio quality at half
the price of other premium audio Brands
and with over 50 000 5 star ratings it's
clearly not just me who thinks so so
what are you waiting for click the link
in the description or go to buy
recon.com forward slash not Mark to get
15 off your raycon purchase
Ichigo obviously refuses because I mean
look at him with a character design like
that I can't exactly blame him Urdu on
the other hand seems to have the
opposite problem where ichigo's power
seems to be spiraling out of his control
as a side effect of his actions in the
Last Arc Urdu in this section seems to
be seeing the consequences his own lack
of power as a choice that he ultimately
made in The Last Arc also and as he's in
the heat of battle with things not going
his way it's revealed that
the interaction with uriu's Father
represents a much more direct approach
from one of the two parental figures in
this Arc and heck even this chapter and
I will be getting to that don't you
worry unlike Ichigo who is dealing with
a physical issue he's terrified of Urdu
is dealing with a moral dilemma his
father proposes he'll get him his powers
back but on one condition in return he
must never involve himself with Soul
Reapers again now I'm interested to see
where this goes as it can offer Urdu two
options number one he betrays his father
sooner rather than later and retains the
good character development he's received
thus far or number two he undergoes a
corruption Arc where he reverts back to
his classic ways gaining a lot of power
in the process think Vegeta during the
Buu saga and this path is also
interesting offering up another Force
for Ichigo to fight against and usually
results in a magnificent moment of
reconciliation at the end again Allah
Vegeta sacrifice and if all of these
inversions in contrast to the specific
encounters with Ichigo and Urdu weren't
enough to suggest that urdu's on a
complimentary or contrasting path to
that of Ichigo ichigo's father 2 gets
introduced as being someone with much
more significant Powers than we
otherwise thought he did
what the hell is happening I was gonna
say I called it with a Talisman his
father gave him as a means of protecting
him because I mean I wasn't wrong about
it being what it was a protection spell
sort of thing but what I was wrong about
his mom being the one with the powers
still 50 is a passing grade and again in
keeping with Ichigo and urdu's
contrasting circumstances unlike urdu's
father ichigo's doesn't appear before
his son but instead in front of the
third and final fight that takes place
in this Arc with Khan and that one
exists entirely for exposition and to be
honest it's good Exposition too it's
Exposition that stems from naturally
sounding conversations and questions
that would be asked by someone like Khan
questions that led us to answers that
explain that this crazy looking creature
here is called an aranca and by
extension this is what the arc is named
after Hollows that take their Mass off
to gain Soul Reaper Powers supposedly
which now that I think about it is sort
of the opposite of what Ichigo seems to
be doing here with the visors a soul
Reaper who puts on a mask to get more
powerful more on that a little later as
mentioned Shinji seems to be offering
Ichigo the chance to take control of his
life however Ichigo does deny this offer
outright before running off to check out
a source of another large spiritual
pressure but honestly this section is
filled with so many different things
that make me rethink this entire story
and double take like urahara's
conversation shortly after with ichigo's
father I honestly don't fully know what
side they are on maybe a division of
Soul Reaper that exists on Earth to
defend it exclusively question mark I
don't know furthermore I still feel like
there's a massive backstory to urahara
that I still don't really know about
he's a bit of an enigma ichigo's father
describes the visors as a lawless gang
of ex-soul Reapers who tried to acquire
Hollow Powers through forbid methods
however given that the soul Society seem
to have issues too it's hard to say cut
and dry whose assessment of who is
correct here or more specifically who we
should believe naturally I think the
answer lies somewhere in the middle but
I do enjoy that we seem to be getting
this bias interpretation from various
groups in the story it helps it feel
much more lively and nuanced however
there is something to take note of with
this specific interaction despite being
able to dispose of this around car in
spectacular fashion this one is far more
developed and powerful than all the
others he's ever faced he suspects Eisen
is behind it thinking he made a deal
with their anchors so that they can help
him achieve his goal whatever that might
be we still don't know at this point
meanwhile Chad and oruhime confront this
newly introduced character hiori and of
course Shinji we are all familiar with
Urdu makes a promise to his father in
exchange for his powers back and so with
that it seems that all the pieces are in
place for the next large-scale set of
plot beats which I will be breaking down
into segments the first of which being
said
tremendous
foreign
car Duo versus the forces of Earth this
is really cool but for a bunch of
different reasons okay as ichigo's
father pointed out moments ago while
they might suspect Eisen to be behind
this we still aren't certain and
furthermore don't even know what he
plans to do if this was all there was to
the plot then I would be singing a very
different tune to the predominantly
positive one I am right now thankfully
the way Kubo has orchestrated and
structured this Arc serves the Slow Burn
and adds an air of mysterious Terror to
these monsters that honestly up until
now have escaped their understanding as
an emotional through Lane we are focused
on ichigo's inner struggle and as it
happens instances like these are what
directly put pressure and emphasis on
that struggle so by virtue of these
characters existing in the story we get
an interesting Dynamic where as an
audience we are satisfied by the direct
impact these newly introduced characters
have on the main source of Interest
Ichigo and the Gang all the while
keeping us receptive to what they they
have to say which as we soon find out
exposits the true nature of this broader
story so let's take a closer look the
sudden arrival of these two grabs the
attention of and sends shockwaves
through all the major casts and me as an
audience member two Iran cars have
arrived on the scene their names I will
not even attempt to try at this point
particularly the little guy I just don't
trust myself with that sort of
responsibility but for now I shall refer
to them as Vegeta and Napa seeing as
their sudden appearance both in a rival
reveal and subsequent action with the
big guy killing a bunch of folks look a
whole lot like when Vegeta and Napa
first touched down on Earth in Dragon
Ball Z all the way down to the framing
of the scene and what sets these two
apart from the creature ichigo's father
contended with earlier is that they are
fully developed
oh
Jesus Christ Chad is he dead and holy
[ __ ] Orihime is a beast saving Chad and
managing to block an attack like that
from this person I'm not even kinda
kidding here oruhime has gone from a
character that pushed me away quite
literally from the series when I was
watching the anime all that time ago to
one of my favorite female characters out
of all the big three this is an
incredibly tense scene with us
potentially on the verge of losing two
important and lovable characters
Punk
is
[Music]
oh thank God okay and this is where the
dynamic I love about this Arc makes
itself known these two put Ichigo in a
bad position but one he's able to
comfortably fight against until suddenly
he starts to struggle and lose the
battle in his mind the depiction of this
in the manga is pretty cool too through
the blacking out of panels I said to
suggest the dark is both figuratively
taking over ichigo's point of view and
literally are pages in this manga this
issue is becoming so serious for Ichigo
that it literally now means that even
with enemies he should have no problem
with he is struggling and in this case
almost died which Not only would have
spelled the end for him but as we've
seen those he too was defending in Chad
and oruhime looking over her in bed
recovering now from that very incident
covered in bandages Ichigo says Chad got
mangle tatsuki was almost killed all
because I was too weak so that's one
problem the other problem well comes by
way of these two tactically retreating
and passing on this message to Eisen
shut up minzy who shares with us part at
least of his plan this acts as an easy
way to once again expose it more about
where a rankers come from how they begin
as menos and how depending on the type
of Menace they start off as how that
will dictate what sort of level the Iran
card that emerges will be Gillian's make
for the weakest of anchors a Duke has
come in the middle of the pack and vasto
Lourdes making for the elite soldier
types but you don't want to be elite
cause Elites got no Integrity the
strength of which are entirely unknown
to us at this point what we do know
however is that Eisen plans on making
more and this is where things start to
get really really good the plot starts
to settle down and we get into the main
body of this Arc following this
occurrence a bunch of familiar faces
from the soul Society show up at Ichigo
School Rukia is among them and it's a
great reveal urukia manages to remind
Ichigo of who he is who she recognizes
him as he needs to become stronger to
protect those that need to be protected
but first we have something much more
interesting to contend with
grimjao's Invasion this is the first
proper invasion of the Ark and our first
true Glimpse at what this story has in
store for us and let me tell you it's
pretty awesome and partially what makes
this Invasion interesting is that
grimjoe went behind eisen's back to take
out the folks he thought the other two
failed to kill and the stuff that spawns
from this is brilliant now obviously
there's Grim Jones fight with Ichigo
that acts as the centerpiece and
justifiably so however there are a few
other fights that occur with the various
Soul Society members after descending
from on high and by far the best battle
that came courtesy of these folks and
maybe even this section has to be the
one with ikaku set up as him looking for
a place to crash the tough guy lacks
attitude that this guy has is infectious
and that honestly surprised me in the
previous Arc I genuinely thought that he
was sort of a joke with his talk of luck
and the quick fashion with which Ichigo
did away with him in the end he seemed
to me at the time him like a gimmick
character but I was wrong
ikaku versus edorad grimjoe having
arrived with a hit squad of five other
individuals one of them makes their way
towards ikaku aiming to kill everyone
with a spiritual pressure and I think I
fell in love with ikaku during this
fight fighting this guy in the name of
finding a place to crash for the night
it stands out charming and fun with
ikaku looking both formidable and kinda
dope not gonna lie but when the aranka
awakens his blade things quickly change
and as things often do in Bleach the
fight gets turned on its head with the
good guy character who was once
dominating finding himself in a dicey
situation get it dicey cause swords
[Music]
and funnily enough things are going so
badly for this dude that this Ally of
his even sends words to organize a
funeral for him but thankfully ikaku has
another Ace up his sleeve
[Music]
this looks sick and furthermore ikaku
comes across as massively impressive and
tenacious from this point on and with
his Bankai being a slow starter the
longer the fight goes on the more
powerful It ultimately stands to become
more shadowing maybe question mark I
don't know his big attack however
doesn't work and the battle just sort of
ends without him dying there's a message
here about valuing life over honor and I
think it's a great thing these types of
manga don't often push but the ending
did feel pretty lackluster compared to
the rest of it particularly after we
find out they're all basically nerfed
and ikaku is the only one of them
outside of Rukia who didn't
yeah who didn't get to show us what he's
really made of so hopefully there's more
to come from this guy later on in the
air Matsumoto renji and toshiro versus
whoever they're fighting this fight is
probably the most busy it involves three
people and largely is there to deliver
one Epic moment and a whole bunch of
necessary information they all win and
defeat their respective our anchors but
it was the announcement that these guys
get to use their full power on Earth
that took the hype level for me to the
max
it's such a great callback to the first
American truth be told I had completely
forgotten about that mechanic and it
really surprised me the main takeaway
from the exposition however that I could
glean was that the main guys we had to
look out for are numbered from 10 to 1
10 being the weakest one being the
strongest and of the main ten apparently
at this moment Grim Zhao is number six
the plot thickens
rimjao vs Ichigo grimjao is a cool name
to see written down grimjao has a really
cool design grimjao is really strong
grimjao is one of the vasto Lourdes and
Chad is isolated but thankfully it's not
grimjo that finds him initially but
another of these rankers called deroy
meaning Ichigo and Rukia need to make
their way towards him to make the save
and you know this is sort of an aside to
this whole fight with Ichigo and grimja
but watching as Chad realizes how
useless and helpless he is now kinda
feels awful the once enormously powerful
Chad now is reduced nothing but an
inconvenience for Ichigo to have to
protect helpless to do anything it's at
this moment in time I realized that I
haven't actually seen Rukia fight as a
soul Reaper since the very first chapter
of the series and I think to myself that
can't be right so if I am mistaken
please point it out in the comments
because that's crazy she sees Ichigo as
being emotionally compromised and so
takes on the big boy herself and she is
off awesome there are numerous instances
where rukia's Soul Reaper blade is
described in detail during the section
also with specific
on how white the blade is it's a blink
and you miss a sort of description but
my obsessive brain feels like there
might be something to that very
description so here's my artistic theory
in this instance I think it's possible
that Kubo the artiste has chosen to use
her White Blade to symbolize a thematic
opposite or complement to ichigo's Black
Blade ayin to his Yang so to speak and
now that I think about it both of these
characters seem to be capable of
bringing balance to their respective
lives her managing to ease ichigo's mind
when he's troubled and he in the past
has in his own way brought balance to
her life by preserving it and not to
mention giving her a friend group so now
that I think about it maybe these two
are special or destined to be partners
or maybe I'm talking out my ass only
time will tell I guess so yeah this
happens damn okay Ichigo gives
everything he has in Bankai form to Grim
Zhao and still nothing grimjao in this
instance is effectively the wall Ichigo
has to overcome in this Arc or lead
shows us how much farther he needs to be
able to go and what's interesting in
this case is that this wall is both
physical in terms of the strength gap
between these two but also highlights
the psychological issues Ichigo is
having currently all the way through
this fight I was waiting for something
Ichigo could do to tear down grimjo and
at one point I was sort of waiting for
Rukia to wake up and get the power boost
from the others but in the end she was
too busy being almost dead each goat in
this instance is very clearly fighting
himself as well as his opponent and if
it wasn't for tozen who arrives at the
last moment to reprimand grimjo for
invading without permission Ichigo and
maybe everyone else could conceivably
have all died but alas he survives to
tell the Tale But loses the battle to
grimjo emphatically I guess we have a
short-term goal to shoot for now in
addition to dealing with ichigo's
performance issues licking their wounds
following this attack everyone is forced
to seek out their own training Ichigo
solicits the help of the visards he once
turned down which brings us to what
seems to be a necessary part of every
bleach Arc training
[Music]
all right so there's this moment that
occurs once Ichigo gets to the visor
base of operations and I'm pretty sure
you all know what I'm talking about it's
really intense and to be honest it gave
me chills while I was reading it
partially because of the artwork
partially because of the implications
that stem from it but mostly due to how
Kubo himself set this very specific
instance up to land as powerfully as it
did in the manga so what am I talking
about exactly well in order to gain
control over the hollow inside of him
trying to take over Ichigo must first
convince those in shinji's company that
he is worth their effort to train in the
first place hiori specifically takes
Ichigo to task and goats him into this
confrontation she assumes her Hollow
form and beats Ichigo into Kingdom Come
terrified to embrace or even contend
with what lurks within him each go
refuses to engage at all with what hiori
is demanding of him but she does force
the hollow out
this look of genuine shock and Trauma on
yori's face then shivers down my spine
now I do not know what this was depicted
or built up like in the anime but in the
manga it was spectacular as I mentioned
before hiuri was introduced alongside
Shinji during one of his confrontations
with Ichigo back in chapter 189 what I
suspect was communicated in the anime
was her boisterous domineering and
unflinching demeanor through voice
acting and clever implementation of
sound effects and animation however in
the manga this I think is magnified in
its own unique ways naturally Her speech
bubbles supersede his in pretty much
every instance she chooses to have her
voice heard however above all else it
was how she dominated the panel space
within the different layouts and pages
that visually communicated her
personality from the moment we saw her
in her literal introductory page her
character appears as though she is
standing on shinji's cowering face let
that sink in her body extending beyond
the parameters of her panel and into
shinjis this is brilliant subtle and
honestly fun visual storytelling this
isn't a girl to be messed with and
certainly not one that scares easily
however when face to face with the
terror of ichigo's Darker half her
disposition changes starkly enhancing
the scene all the more with the
split-second he had her by the throat
and the reaction from her friends
showing us all we needed to know
concerning how serious that instance in
time truly was and what follows this is
effectively a confirmation of what I
anticipated this story to be about one
where Ichigo learns to live with an
aspect of who he is and refuses to allow
that aspect he's terrified of to consume
him and determine what he is you could
look at this as a metaphor for
confronting your problems not allowing
the act of avoiding them to send you
spiraling and to dictate to yourself who
you really are rather than be ruled by
the risk of losing Yourself by what you
dislike about yourself it's also a scene
where we get to meet a load of Shinji
and hiori's allies they are fun silly
and I just love it when Kubo adds some
fun new characters to the mix but I
digress the premise for this is simple
and how it's visually explored is fun to
watch also essentially Ichigo gets to
fight himself in his own mind all the
while the state of the fight itself is
being depicted outwardly in ichigo's
body as he slowly and then quickly
becomes literally consumed by the hollow
he's fighting within it's really cool to
look at and particularly when the
monster starts to lose limbs only to
regenerate them instantly and to be
honest it looks kinda sick I'm not gonna
lie there's a wonderful framework for
the fight that keeps this both
consistent and straightforward to follow
Halo Ichigo consistently refers to
himself as zangetsu implying beyond the
obvious that he is in fact his weapon
and like any great weapon it needs a
wielder worthy of its potential
furthermore after addressing Ichigo as
King right off the bat when he arrives I
enjoyed the metaphor that was being
drawn of the difference between a horse
and the King that rides the horse into
battle naturally ichigo's darker half
believes that the right course of action
is bloody murder left right and center
and there are some wonderful quotes from
this section too how can you slay with a
sheath sword speaking talking to the
failure of ichigo's very logic however
the important thing to learn here isn't
to fully Embrace and give control to
Halo Ichigo because the opposite of that
isn't very good either but to instead
use the power in a controlled and
effective way because if he doesn't he
becomes as useless as a sheath sword as
he mentioned and it seems that Ichigo
gets that message at least partially
grabbing the sword embedded in his
abdomen pulling it from the grasp of his
hollow form visually saying that he is
once again taking control taking the
Reigns of this altercation punctuated by
him taking out his hollow counterpart
with one powerful thrust of his sword
his black color once again dominating
his form reclaiming the blade used
against him Ichigo emerges Victorious
however something that I will keep in
mind is that this isn't over while
Ichigo has won this particular battle he
has not yet learned the life-changing
lesson that will win him the war within
as Halo Ichigo reminds him before
Vanishing into a subconscious
[Music]
so while this bodes well for Ichigo in
the short term I wonder how long he has
until he finds himself on his knees
looking deep within asking himself how
badly he wants to win again I was
recently told that when devising a name
for the story tight Kubo noted that
while Shinigami are associated with
black black itself would be a boring
name for the series white suggested
black as a complementary color and he
therefore chose bleach to evoke the
impression of the color white these
colors black and white seem to be
intertwined with the DNA of the story
both narratively and Visually there are
a lot of things this story could in its
Essence be about but in my opinion it is
specifically about the struggle ichigo's
inner conflict represents the
fascination Kubo has with the contrast
white evokes onto black speaks to this
very Direction it's emblematic of and
draws attention to the central conflict
of this lung series light versus dark
suggesting not that one is superior to
the other but that one needs both to
achieve balance chapter 219 Page 6 and 7
demonstrate this very conflict visually
and is not until one side succumbs to
the other that this contrast and
conflict in the page layout stops and
the two colors representing Ichigo merge
into one scene on the hilt of this sword
in chapter 221 returning to the land of
the living with a mask now one side
emboldened and marked with black and the
other side clear and white signifying
that when apart they are Hollow and that
only when working together are they
truly whole and this very aspect is
something that is drawing attention to
when orehime is seasoned for the very
first time after this reconciliation of
the two halves ichigo's getting really
strong and not in a scary way like
before but it's not in a nice way either
suggesting perhaps that he has found a
balance a mix of both and this is where
the main conflict that informs the rest
of the arc comes in now that Ichigo is
no longer fighting with himself at least
for the time being he has regained his
ability to be useful to save lives to
protect his allies and town from the
coming conflict as Eisen readies to
destroy his home and gather 100
000 souls he has friends that are
willing to much like him give up their
lives in an effort to defend those that
need defending and given that he is the
one with the most power potential that
responsibility as a protector lands on
his shoulders conversely Orihime Chad
and urdu's training has a light shot on
it for the first time during this period
too however oruhime gets far more
attention and honestly I think
rightfully so towards the beginning of
this Arc a greater emphasis was placed
on urdu's journey and choice he needed
to make but in reality has gotten very
little Focus since with a tremendous
amount of the emphasis placed on
introducing new character systems and
mechanics and while I think this is
rightfully done as it is important for
us to understand what's going on moving
forward I'm happy that at the very least
the likes of puriu Chad and especially
Orihime have an opportunity to express
their frustrations wants and goals in
this portion there's a fantastic moment
moment towards the beginning of
grimjao's first Invasion where Chad is
shown to be defenseless and unable to
help Ichigo in his fight for the very
first time he has become the person who
was helpless and Powerless a burden in
the way and I hope more of this aspect
of Chad's character is explored in the
future as he trains relentlessly the
philosophy his very character
represented in the First Act was
profound but was spoken to from the
point of view of someone that was
powerful knowing what to do with that
power however now we get to see him
vulnerable the powerful has become the
weak and so I'm interested to see how he
reacts to this new status quo shift will
he Thrive or just expire and lose
relevancy only time I guess we'll tell
but for me it was orohime's
participation in this Arc that has once
again been the highlight as I mentioned
moments ago Kubo has gone to a
tremendous amount of effort to have this
be a story concerning Ichigo but more
accurately and generally the struggle in
one's heart to be the best that they can
be with the differences that emerge
between the hosts of different
characters that populate this manga
showcasing that for us specifically
Orihime is terrific for this very reason
sharing in her own personal struggle in
trying to desperately not be a burden
which like Chad also hearkens back to
her struggle in the First Act with her
brother all the while in this Arc acting
as a character with enough emotional
maturity to point out for us clear
examples of our friends changing for the
bad and for the good I mentioned that
she noticed when Ichigo seemed to find
balance within himself being a force to
be reckoned with but that quote and that
scene really only works in the first
place because of what we've heard her
say in the past she's pointed out when
Khan was in ichigo's body that that
wasn't Ichigo she's always picked up on
when Ichigo himself is feeling off and
earlier in this very Arc in order to
create the appropriate contrast for when
Ichigo eventually achieves balance she
points out in chapter 193 on page 7 that
while in his Bankai form Ichigo feels
different fiercer grittier like it's not
even him anymore while he's at war with
himself I adore stuff like this is an
Orihime story is being fully embraced
and explored we've seen her insecurities
following her inability to pick up
Ichigo when he was down and we've seen
her jealousy when it comes to how
successful rupiah has become in doing
just that being unlike Ichigo who seems
to constantly struggle with finding his
inner balance Orihime hasn't yet fallen
or allowed those weaker and darker
feelings she's had impede her ability to
see reality well that was until she
straight up was told to her face that
she isn't enough and should take a
backseat courtesy of Mr kisuke following
this news she's picked up by the person
she envied in Rukia and because she
never burned that very Bridge Rukia was
able to pick her up in the same way she
was able to help Ichigo it's a wonderful
and engaging Dynamic these characters
share reinforcing once again that
bleach's strongest attribute at least to
me is in its character writing
foreign
with everyone having trained for the
last month this is about where the first
Arc of this much longer irankar Arc or
saga comes to its final big set piece
and with this conclusion comes a
refocusing on a particular character
with the story going in a much needed
New Direction I could feel this shift
coming on the horizon and the best part
was I had no idea where it was coming
from and more importantly where it would
go and I thought the results were not
perfect was an interesting decision to
say the least so let's talk about the
fights in this Invasion and more
specifically what they actually came
here for in the first place
Grim Zhao vs Ichigo take two Electric
Boogaloo I think one of the best
decisions this Arc made was to introduce
grimjo as this chaotic and unpredictable
character thanks to him as an audience
there is this air of uncertainty as
we're reading while he's on screen we
don't know what they are here for just
yet but we suspect grimjo could be
acting on his own or going off script at
any moment unlike Ichigo who's a great
reactionary character grimjao is a
fantastic foil to create that plot for
Ichigo to ultimately react to and so
this fight at least while I was reading
it got the majority of my focus which I
can only imagine was the best case
scenario for Kubo in aiding in what he
ultimately wants to achieve with this
part A misdirection and let me tell you
it totally got me but concerning the
fight itself there are a few noteworthy
additions and changes to the status quo
to justify this rematch and very much
inject interest grimjao is weakened and
Ichigo has a cool new party trick a
party trick that functions in the same
way as my favorite move from Dragon Ball
does the Kaioken Kaio what much like the
kaio-ken this qualification offers
Ichigo the chance to boost his speed and
power tremendously however only for a
short amount of time and with a great
cost or risk to himself if he exceeds
that time window well bad stuff can
happen and because of this apart from
looking cool in every sense of the word
it also brings with it a new level of
tension to the fight we wait for Ichigo
to use it we anticipate how his foe will
react and deal with this new power and
we worry every single moment he uses it
because as of right now he can only use
it for like 11 seconds which is a
hilariously short amount of time for a
power boost in a fight I might even go
as far as to say that it offers
something more than Kaioken does in
Dragon Ball and therefore might be more
interesting to me because there is that
added fear of not just physical over
exertion but the collapse of ichigo's
mind too it's a brilliant ruffle to this
already engaging and fun moves that each
go has at his disposal
it's got tissue
the initial attack each go lands is
stunning and seeing grimjo scared after
being so cocky is honestly thrilling
each girl utterly obliterates him in one
attack leaving Grim Zhao stunned and
confused by the difference Ichigo is
demonstrating in his ability the Fight
Continues for a few moments with each
goal Landing another big attack
but his mask crumbles and he's out of
time
Switching gears for a second and I will
go back to this don't worry we check out
what's going on at the same time with
toshiro ikaku this guy and Matsumoto
with their rankers
urahada shows up to fight never in my
life have I needed something so much and
never known until I received it
realizing that this was one of if not
the only time I had seen urahara fight
properly made it all the more compelling
as I told us possibly quite a bit about
his character arriving in time to make
the save on Matsumoto throughout this
battle he uses many different
interesting tactic based approaches not
limited to a decoy gigai proving himself
to be a very analytical fighter much
more brains than Braun though not lucky
in either Department really it very much
paints him as a thinking man Soul Reaper
which is a nice change of pace and an
interesting fighting style in keeping
with what little I know already about
urahara as of right now alright so
that's that fight how are things going
with Ichigo again
foreign
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
don't lose
yes yes
[Music]
after leaving orohime to take the long
way home from Soul Society urukia
arrives just in the nick of time to
block a devastating attack from grimjao
unto Ichigo one that would have surely
been his end with grim Zhang now Frozen
Rukia moves to check on Ichigo but gets
grabbed by grimjo and then
don't lose your weight
holy [ __ ] again Shinji saves the day
this was brilliant to sit and read
through he even fires his own several
blasted him which is really cool that he
uses Hollow based moves it's just
something that I don't really see that
often nevertheless grimjo blocks at the
last possible moment before being
stopped in his tracks by okiora who
quietly informs him that apparently the
mission has already been accomplished
Orihime has been secured she was the
target I did not see that coming and
neither did Ichigo and thus sets up the
next arc's goal and it's a goal I can
one thousand percent get behind because
as I said I love her character and what
follows this is perhaps the best orohime
chapter of all time or at least thus far
in the series but before I get into that
I'd like to touch on one aspect of this
Saga or Arc if you want to call it that
that I didn't like it was a choice that
was instrumental in creating these
circumstances that while good came about
in a sort of strange way and it's all
because of a really dumb decision
urahara made as someone that's depicted
as this analytical and strategic
individual his reasoning for pushing
Orihime away like he did to stay out of
the battle seems so incredibly
short-sighted and irresponsible if he
knew or suspected they would come for
her why not guard her why not tell her
why leave her defenseless this is what I
personally don't like in stories Kubo
clearly needed orohime to get captured
in private by this specific individual
and in order to achieve that Kubo
decided to compromise a specific
character's Integrity it's not a
decision I can get behind personally so
let's just move on oruhime's goodbye
unlike other arcs this one concludes on
a very somber note offering not Ichigo
but instead Orihime the spotlight a
private moment of introspection
vulnerability no other character has
shared with us thus far in this series
it's moments like this I adore when a
story takes the time to explore and bask
any specific character's mental space
after being given this bracelet that
wraps her in a special spiritual
membrane she has 12 hours to say her
goodbyes to one person and one person
only they won't be able to hear or
perceive her but she does choose one
person and it's Ichigo her goodbye to
the man she loves is the sweetest
chapter this manga has delivered and the
karakubo places on the smallest of
boomans is truly touching it
Illuminating for us as Ichigo rests the
world oruhime dreams of one where she
could be all the different things she
loves and is interested in she is after
all a very sporadic and eclectic
character however no matter how many
interests she might have no matter how
many foods she might like or jobs she
might conceivably try in her lifetime no
matter how many versions of her might be
possible she admits that they would all
fall in love with Ichigo and that right
there that not only is a beautifully
sweet sentiment but is one as true to
her as any other piece of dialogue that
has ever been written by Kubo for her
and it's I think one of the strongest
examples of character writing in this
entire series it's truly a fantastic
scene and a brilliant chapter
interesting however yet another example
of good Exposition despite being in some
sort of Astral form that's supposedly
imperceptible she manages to heal him
before she goes leaving behind her
unique spiritual pressure and ultimately
providing a brilliant way of sending a
signal without breaking the claws of
what her bracelet represents which
brings us to the end of this Arc with
orohime in the clutches of Eisen and our
heroes reading themselves for an
adventure to a dangerous land unlike any
that we've yet come across in this story
I do have some concerns while I am
invested in orohime's story and her
relationship with her friends
particularly Ichigo I am also aware that
this is a very similar setup to that of
the Soul Society Arc so from this point
on I'm curious to see what Kubo can
offer in the way of differentiating or
adding variety to the mix in this
situation as this does have a few
important differences to the soul
Society to play with not the least of
which is the character of Eisen having
been established as well as these new
creatures but only time will tell and
for you all watching you don't have to
wait to see my thoughts on this like I
did because this is a special two-part
video so let's dive straight into the
next Arc of The Saga without delay
[Music]
I want to say from the outset before
diving into this section that if my
opinions don't line up with your own it
should go without saying that I'm not
trying to invalidate your experience
many of you watching have either
exclusively watched the anime which I
haven't and or have read the Manga while
it was coming out weekly which I didn't
this Arc has a lot and I mean a lot of
fighting so when it comes to the pacing
reading week to week I can totally
imagine a world where that would have
been irritating for some readers out
there however my experience binging the
whole thing this week has been massively
positive so I figured before we venture
forth into the void Beyond of hueco
Mundo that was worth addressing now one
of the biggest criticisms of this Arc is
that it feels too much like the soul
society and having read over 60 chapters
of this Arc now I can see where that
criticism is coming from and it isn't
entirely unfounded structurally there
are a lot of similarities and if you
really want to strip it down to its bare
components it is a chunk of story
contending with freeing one of their
female friend friends from captivity
after they willfully go there in an
effort to protect their friends from
danger that is unavoidably true however
I think suggesting that it is a carbon
copy of the previous Arc with nothing
new to offer is going entirely too far
while it is important to accept the
similarities I think it's critical if we
want to be balanced and fair to also
take note of what this particular story
is trying to achieve because it's quite
a bit different to Soul Society in some
important ways first of all in a similar
fashion to that of the substitute
Shinigami Arc it's impossible to divorce
the significance of what that first
Invasion or first part of this greater
akur Saga did in order to lead into this
particular section while the driving
force of Soul Society was to broadly
speaking Shining Light on ichigo's
personal development and rukia's
interpersonal development through he
having to learn to trust himself and
Rukia learning to see herself as someone
worth the time of day the aranca r
clearly has its own unique story it
wants to tell that continues the
Journey's explore through the likes of
substitute Shinigami and soul Society
respectively in other words they are
similar in structure but totally
different in what they're trying to
achieve and I think that's important how
Ichigo performs and develops in this Arc
is a direct Evolution from Soul Society
it's part of his journey and having now
completed that Last Arc his exploits in
that very story have led him to making
some fundamental errors in the opposite
direction with this one where he himself
wishes now to take on all the
responsibility denying his friends the
chance to contribute to the greater
Mission and give it a greater chance of
success so in a way ichigo's story in
this Arc not only is different to Seoul
Society but it's the exact opposite it
focuses on what is outwardly happening
and concerning each goal rather than
solely what is inside him and it does
show through the fight that this story
offers also could this story have been
told in a different way with a different
structure to that of Soul Society yeah
probably but it didn't detract at all
from what I like about this Arc because
as I've outlined right now this is only
the midsection of this greater aranca
Arc and it goes in a very different
direction All Things Considered which is
the most important thing for me but
enough Preamble what did I think of this
arc's events so Ichigo arrives at Mr
urahara's place and hops into the void
Beyond reluctantly with the help of Chad
and uru who Justified to him to go on
this Mission because Ichigo is
technically going against the orders of
the Soul Society it's a tenuous at best
excuse but his dad almost certainly
won't buy but it is still technically
correct which as we all know is the best
kind of correct there's some interesting
seeds set also with the likes of tasku
that I assume will be addressed when
they return in the next section of the
story and following that we get some
really interesting insight into how
important oruhime might actually become
to not only this story but Ichigo
specifically and his journey I'm about
to share a prediction a theory if you
will so put your tin foil hats on we
learned that Orihime is effectively this
miracle Hill so much so that she can
restore individuals bodies to a point
where they once were perfectly fine it's
sort of like rebooting to previous save
files it's nuts grimjao lost his arm
earlier in the story but now he has it
back so this is where my Theory comes in
the theme and well really the soft goal
of this greater Arc is to explore the
importance of trust and teamwork for
Ichigo to fight against shouldering the
weight of the world alone when others
can help for when Ichigo does shoulder
the world's problems he runs the risk of
losing himself to the hollow inside of
him it's a cool consequence of him over
exerting himself that I know will
eventually happen later on in the story
it just has to so what if when he does
what if he does lose himself and can't
bring himself back from the brink until
orehime steps in what if her powers
Grant her the ability to do just that
that would keep her as the focus of the
story while also playing into the theme
of trust and teamwork being a necessary
part of what Ichigo should learn to
appreciate the weakest in terms of
battle now suddenly becomes the most
crucial component of making Ichigo one
of the most powerful live up to his
potential now this is just a theory but
I think it's a good one I'm sure if
nothing else she'll be healing him
sporadically throughout this journey
which again reinforces the themes
anyways oh and before moving on there's
this conversation with the Two Dads of
Ichigo and uriu that doesn't manifest in
anything meaningful within this section
so I'll hold off on discussing that
until it does become relevant the
arrival the initial Landing in the land
of the arancas hueco Mundo is pretty
cool there's a decent amount of variety
in the environment from scene to scene
whether it be battles in the desert
Runnings in a castle-like structure or
just voids of Darkness with the likes of
Eisen and a certain other Cayenne
character and with that variety comes
uru and Chad's chance to demonstrate how
capable they truly have become by
kicking the asses of these lowly rankers
I guess it's great that we're
reinforcing the themes of this story
right off the bat and we get an idea of
what awaits them on this journey this is
also a nice touch with Ernie's character
that's drawn attention to early on as
he's able to absorb and become empowered
by the reishi in the atmosphere of this
place thus boosting his powers however
while this is cool and leads to some
cool moments for him specifically there
isn't much relevance to this reishi
being in the atmosphere beyond the power
boost for him specifically it doesn't
facilitate any narrative switch if that
makes sense at least not yet that I've
read anyway it did however bring to my
attention that rookiem might be an
anomaly when it comes to regaining her
powers through reishi seeing as Ichigo
can seem to absorb it for his benefit
like urukan
[Music]
this is Nell and this is when we meet
Mel and her friends and when I first met
them I thought they were fine albeit a
little cumbersome I did figure that they
were going to be our Exposition sidekick
type characters for a lack of a better
term in this journey but I was wrong
really wrong Nell is awesome but for now
they need saving
[Music]
okay rookie is here that is cool now we
have another person for Ichigo to be
okay with working alongside this is
great but this is also the point where
we arrive at a Crossroads so to speak
with multiple passageways open to
explore and Rukia suggests
to split up now personally I've always
been with Shaggy on this one splitting
up looking for Clues opens the gang up
to all sorts of Mayhem and while good
for the purposes of Scooby-Doo and
apparently this Arc for tension I don't
think it's unreasonable for Ichigo to
say that this might be a bad idea there
are better ways to communicate his urge
to push away from accepting help than by
trusting his friends to isolate
themselves in the most dangerous place
that currently exists in this world but
whatever I guess we're splitting up
ichco's first encounter on this path of
his is quite tough he's forced to turn
into his hollow form again for like a
second and the fight is weirdly long but
honestly I'm not sure exactly why it is
I want to talk about this arc's action
and sheer quantity of its fighting but
again I have that saved for later in
this video so look forward to that from
what I can gather there's some
reinforcement of themes in this fight as
well as demonstrating to us that Nell is
something special something much more
important than this impish character she
seems to be showing because in addition
to this crazy Carol or cereal blast she
also has healing capabilities
while I haven't dedicated much time of
this review to touch on what Urdu has
been doing I do want to show some
appreciation to this new Dynamic made
between this aranca companion of Nels
Who's acting as the funny man to uru
straight man I don't know how this
translates in the anime but in the manga
it's pretty inoffensive and I got a
giggle out of me here and there that
aside what I do think is worth
mentioning however is the conclusion to
the fight he has with this random bugger
anchor that's number 105. he whips out
this new move and does away with her
relatively easily All Things Considered
similarly to Ichigo uriu didn't want to
use his Ace in the Hole just yet however
unlike Ichigo which saw him and Nell
show Mercy where you didn't leaving
their victims there helpless it isn't
mentioned again in this section but I
think it is a good contrast that was
made between these two that is obviously
showcased by its placing in the story
but enough about that let's talk about
Chad what did I think of his
contribution to this section well not a
lie because Chad doesn't get a lot in
this section if I'm being honest but he
did get a pretty sweet new Shield to
attach to his arm who'd have known that
was hiding in there okay Jokes Aside
it's cool that in keeping with his
philosophy that he isn't an attacker but
a Defender the guy grew his shield to
protect people and what's more is he
even unlocks his other arm in an
offensive measure he is neither Soul
Reaper nor Quincy he says but a human
channeling Hollow powers and so I guess
we have the trifecta a Quincy a hollow
and a soul Reaper however following that
he runs into this a ranker and promptly
goes to sleep for the rest of this video
thanks for coming Chad you're a real
hero it is cool though getting to see
everyone remark on the sudden loss of
his spiritual pressure including oruhime
that does put a lot of pressure on her
once again however thankfully following
this we get a much more interesting
scene Rukia versus her demons this one
is really creepy and in ways felt way
too real like this scene legit fooled me
and still kinda has me fooled I don't
know so while hurrying to Chad's
location to help him Rukia gets
blindsided by some a Rancor that knocks
her into the Shadows the perfect dark
environment to tackle this subject
matter might I add because it's revealed
that this is cayenne
I'm sorry uh what he explains how he got
there and that he has a plan but right
at the end when he has her trust he just
straight up attacks her she just about
manages to dodge this but this just gave
me chills while reading I've touched on
this in other videos but there's a
technique in writing called dramatic
irony and it's used when we as an
audience know more than the characters
in the scene do it's a common technique
it's really effective it's popular in
pantomime with people shouting to the
poor actors on stage at the bad guy is
behind them or whatever you know it's
good for building tension but this scene
decides to do the exact opposite and
keep us just as unsure as Rukia is and
man is it creepy and Brilliant all at
the same time the following chapter is
filled with manipulation that feels
wrong and yet flirts with being
strangely believable too it's wonderful
it ends with rookie demanding that
whoever this is to never say cayenne's
name again watching this ranker at will
explain their powers and and transformed
back into Cayenne is terrifying and
depicted quite unsettlingly too by Kubo
might I add I think the fact that they
try so earnestly to convince her that
they are in fact Cayenne time and again
is the most unsettling aspect of it they
consume dead Hollows and take their
powers and this is great but it does
remind me of what I want to talk about
and that's the fights in this Arc and
some of the ones that I've glossed over
I want to explain why I've done this so
here it goes bleach's battles in the
interest of being fair because this
review is largely very positive I think
it's also important to draw attention to
this arcs and perhaps bleach's weakest
aspect that I've noticed thus far when
there is such for many of the series
detractors and that is the repetitive
cyclical and perhaps formulaic nature of
many of its fight scenes one of the few
parameters of a story I am privy to
before I begin my blind read-throughs
like this is the length of the material
and one of the concerns I had going into
this when I noticed its length was how
it was going to you those fights to
create interest in that time frame
brevity for me is a virtue in a story so
when I see a lot of chapters I hope for
its sake that it makes use of that time
rather than just bloat itself for Bleach
like many other Shonen stories fighting
is the language of its narrative and
Story characters progress through
difficult mental blocks compromising
circumstances and come out on top or
fail in order to propel the story forth
into the next story beat this is
important I love it and particularly for
the likes of Ichigo his entire story is
centered around the defense of his
friends from danger through fighting
where my gripes however stem from in
this case is through the lack of variety
when it comes to many of the fight
structure that don't involve Ichigo the
main character specifically or heck
sometimes even those that do the soul
society and this hueco Mundo section
provide a lot of this particularly with
its secondary characters where a good
guy and bad guy confront each other
there's sometimes a back and forth one
of them reveals a big power boost and
the other guy looks concerned only to
then reveal that he too has a big Power
move leading to that person either
picking up the victory or someone else
coming in to make the save last minute
if that person is on the back foot and
is a good guy there are plenty of
repetitive scenes that follow this
structure and when it came to Soul
Society I found this all the more
irritating because at the time Kubo
struggled to keep the secondary cast
like Orihime Chad and uriu relevant
contributing members of the story and as
I mentioned because the story of this
manga is told through fighting if their
fights don't contribute to the story
then it feels very much like bloat or
filler and while that didn't bother me
all that much while I was reading it all
in one go I can absolutely empathize
with someone who read this as a weekly
release it's an entirely different set
of circumstances compared to what I have
at my disposal right now however and
this is a big however I will say that
because bleed structures its fights this
way Kubo actually managed to deliver a
genuinely impactful surprise to me and
it was through rukia's fight with this
imposter Kaya as I mentioned when it
feels like a particular outcome is built
up to it's normally superseded by a
quote unlikely save at the last minute
this of course creates the problem that
when something unlikely happens all the
time then it becomes likely and worse
again predictable however during this
build up to rookie is spirit being
broken and this fake Cayenne lining up
his final shot to take her out because
the good versus evil Dynamic was so well
defined because it felt like Kuba was
writing her to feel broken because of
what I had experienced in this story all
the way leading up to this when Kubo
actually followed through with it and
showed rookia legitimately get impaled I
was utterly shocked prior to this I had
found myself thinking oh here we go
again who's gonna make the save on her
this to only to turn the page and
discover that nope no one did so
ironically enough this was a nice
misdirection by doing what we were told
was likely to happen in the first place
I don't think I've ever experienced that
with a manga before so that was kind of
cool made all the more effective to me
by how it managed to after this segue
nicely into a flashback for rookia
herself to reconcile her relationship
with cayenne this number 9 a ranker has
offered her the chance to exercise her
Demons by accepting that while cayenne's
powers and body might be fighting her
his heart will always be with her she
lives on to carry his memory to not die
alone it's a wonderful conclusion to a
great series of chapters and ironically
enough was made all the better due to a
gripe I believe I had with bleach's
action and what's more is that unlike
Pyrex where I've complained people tend
to get stabbed only to then Shake It Off
moments later this Arc keeps people down
rookie get impaled well she's out for
the count now and the same is true for
Chad so I really do appreciate that it
creates more tension around the future
fights that take place I realize at this
point I probably should also explain
what a good example of fights driving
the narrative looks like I've pointed
out issues I've had with bleach so let's
look at a story that I think does it
quite well in places so we all know
Dragon Ball it's not the perfect series
but I have a fondness for it and I think
most of us know it pretty well and one
thing it does really well I think is
using fighting to drive its narrative
particularly in Dragon Ball Z and early
Dragon Ball Dynamic and Frieza Arc is
one of my favorite arcs of all time and
this is one of the reasons why it's easy
to interweave the narrative and
importance into the more pivotal fights
like the Ginyu Force and Frieza so let's
look at something a little more lower in
scope and Stakes Vegeta vs zarbon they
have two fights together the two fights
are very different and they both tell
two parts of a greater story initially
Vegeta strikes up a fight with tsarbon
thinking that he's the cat's pajamas
only to find out he's really the dog's
dinner that is until he recovers and
comes back stronger than ever to
overpower and kill zarbon this fight in
addition to telling a self-contained
story of arrogance and struggle also has
significant consequences zarbon one of
the main people underneath Frieza dies
and what's more is without this fight
the zenkai Boost mechanic that was
introduced wouldn't be nearly as clear
as it otherwise ends up being and so if
you remove this fight the story itself
makes much less sense as a result and so
that's when you know you have for
yourself a good addition to a story when
a fight ticks all these boxes you've got
yourself a fight that drives the
narrative and while I do love what the
fights in this Arc offer rookia with her
personal story and what they offer Chad
with his physical development I just
wish that in addition to having an
impact on the character's personal
Journeys they would also have a greater
consequence for the broader Arc I mean
within this section that I'm covering
Chad just goes to this realm to get a
shield and sleep for a while okay that's
a bit harsh but still if the goal of
this Arc is to get Ichigo to trust in
others more why are we not using these
characters to drive home the value of
that mentality instead of making the
these individuals just another name on a
list of people that he has to save but
maybe this would be rectified in the
next section who knows maybe I'm
speaking too soon it's not a huge deal
just something I thought was worth
mentioning
stuff like this was really cool because
each ghost priorities are evident for
all of us to see in this interaction and
it sort of highlights what's interesting
about a rankers when compared to Hollows
there's a Nuance to how they go about
things they're all different in
personality and morality to Wild degrees
with many appearing totally innocuous
and nice While others are well Neutra
and in this case Ichigo seems to have no
interest or need to fight ulkiora and
just moves on until
[Music]
yeah okay [ __ ] this guy following this
we turn the page and the once
disinterested Ichigo walking away is
seen clashing in an instant with this
aranca it's an extremely effective use
of the page Turn 2 by the way and from
that moment on Ichigo just goes all out
but this time to no effect I love the
paneling in this short sequence it's all
laid out to make UL Kiara as clinical
and matter of fact as possible not to
mention imposing he doesn't boast or
have much bravado about him but he does
watch he does block and he does tell it
as it is and he reveals to Ichigo that
his best isn't enough and that
furthermore
[Music]
he's only number four meaning there are
three people stronger than him he leaves
each go defeated after one strike and
doesn't kill him now that's interesting
at least to me correct me if I'm wrong
but it looks as though he hasn't killed
anyone yet in fact he's done the
opposite reprimanding that very behavior
in grimjoe and speaking of grimjao with
Ichigo lying lifeless in the previous
scene he reminds me of why I love his
character
metal
the plot just happens when this guy is
on screen each go is great and all that
but it's so obvious why people love Grim
job unlike the majority of the
characters in this story he actually
makes decisions that aren't reacting to
something and these decisions he
actually makes have consequences along
with Orihime this guy is a driving force
that keeps me engaged with the story
grimjao just shows up at ichigo's body
heals Ichigo with Orihime that is a
brilliant Twist of the plot by the way
it's interesting and because we already
have an idea of what grimjoe is like as
a character we kind of understand why
he's doing this he wants a rematch and
hilariously once all Kiora catches wind
of this the dude comes back into frame
for like three seconds before grimjo
just puts him in timeout for like three
hours and jokes aside while it's not
mentioned again in this section this
weird time out thing grimjao uses here
it has to be a mechanic used in the
climax of this Arc its use here is just
too perfect for it not to be so I'm
calling it now this technique or
whatever it is is going to be used in
the climax to some significant great it
just has to be the fight itself between
grimjo and the bleach man himself is
brilliant and one aspect of it that
really caught my attention is the amount
of focus ichigo's eyes receive from
Orihime who has to believe she can see
each go in there anymore and on the
opposite side of the spectrum Grim Joe
or Max frustratedly that Ichigo always
has this look in his eye with or without
the mask perhaps alluding to the idea
that we are all not simply one emotion
or one component but instead a complex
web of attributes and qualities that
shine through at different times the
idea behind ichigo's fight is that he is
using the monster inside of him to
achieve a goal and to do that he must
put his more sensitive qualities to one
side and embrace the more animalistic
side of himself thus creating what
crimjo sees in him when they fight
consistently and the distance that
appears between orohime and what she's
familiar with when she peers into him
usually however it is important to point
out that it's not entirely gone in fact
I would go as far as to say that that
point is crucial pointed out to us
during this fight when onihime finally
incur encouraged Ichigo that that part
of him that's fighting for the right
reasons is still there and it's in the
driver's seat and he's able to turn that
positivity into physical results thereby
showing us the utility of that positive
virtuous quality over simply losing
oneself to base urges for war and pain
in other words a controlled anger
instead of a Mindless storm
so this bit I found quite interesting as
we get to interact with this
legitimately threatening character while
also learning a great deal about L but
before that
during this time there's this other
fight and it's been a section of the
story I haven't been showing a lot of
love to in this review and that's
because for the most part renji and uriu
despite being characters I otherwise
enjoy their fights in this section
honestly feel like afterthoughts and as
the other plotline that's currently
running alongside the main one it feels
so much less interesting and
consequential by comparison and that
sucks I want to see these guys but every
time we switch to them all I think about
is how much longer I have to wait until
we get back to the actual story here and
it's not because their fight is bad but
more so because it doesn't seem to
proceed at all while we are spending
time there anyway back to now
foreign
this is the first conclusive piece of
evidence that these high-level ranking
rankers aren't always evil creatures
they're not monstrous but she does have
monstrous power however she's from a
time that has since passed and our power
ranking is outdated so let's see how she
fares against this chap there's a really
good flashback to the previous fight
Neutra number five then number eight had
with Nell following his defeat in their
last jewel in the past it's filled with
some really great quotes and here's a
few she says after he demands she kill
him we are humans who became Hollows
then regained our Reason by becoming a
rankers rational beings need a reason to
kill and you don't have one Neutra
frustrated says that he does that he
doesn't like her and she responds that's
not a reason that's an instant you're a
beast I don't recognize you as a warrior
and I refuse to burden myself with your
life apart from being a cold as hell
response from Nell here the back and
forth person really bleach his whole
philosophy when it comes to fight scenes
has caused me to reflect quite a bit on
what exactly makes a fight scene
captivating I spoke prior about how
story structure can be communicated
through fighting but I think it's only
fairy I also draw attention to something
bleach does better than most other
fight-centric stories with regards to
its action it's this notion of good
versus evil rational versus instinctual
light versus dark that seems to dominate
not just manga not just Western media
but as permeated throughout most
cultures I don't want to get too broad
and fundamental here but I think bleach
Taps into something sort of foundational
when it comes to our appreciation as a
species for fighting when you look at
Fighters like Anthony Joshua Tony
Ferguson and Conor McGregor you see more
than just a fighter you see a story it's
one of the reasons why the WWE has been
so successful and persistent across
multiple decades the fight itself is
interesting but it's the story that
comes along with it that makes it the
whole package speaking of someone from
Ireland back in the day my father
brothers and heck even my work colleague
colleagues would go on and on about how
amazing Conor McGregor's Journey was how
he came from virtually nothing and put
it on the line every single night to
achieve his goal we watch for that story
we see ourselves in that tale and when
opportunities presented themselves were
the hero of the story Falls we get
further engrossed because those are the
moments that define us will the darkness
in those moments you needed to channel
in combat overtake you and Define who
you are or will you be able to push
forward and do the right thing
irrespective of your circumstances in
the case of Conor McGregor following his
second fight against Dustin Poirier it's
clear to see what happened confused and
ashamed he spewed vulgar nothing insults
out of instinct a pathetic final gasp to
keep fighting for the sake of it despite
the conclusion already having been
reached and I think bleach is playing
with those same ideas foundational
principles of not just fighting but
vicarious story time that we as a
society look to for inspiration can we
see someone go to the brink put
themselves in into that dark place and
emerge once again as intact rational and
good people or will they become a slave
to the very darkness that they utilized
a monster lacking in rational thought
fighting out of as Nell puts it instant
concerning bleach this becomes
particularly interesting when we add our
rankers into the mix at this point we've
clearly seen where Hollows come from and
we also understand that our anchors
themselves come from Hollows but not all
our rankers are monsters sort of in the
same way that not all Soul Reapers are
good and not all quinces are bad so what
does this mean it further adds a layer
of gray Nuance to each encounter proving
that our anchors by virtue of being what
they are do not necessarily mean that
they themselves have been consumed by
that very Darkness Ichigo is so afraid
of but yeah these are just the thoughts
I have following this section as Nell
returns to being a child and the fight
becomes less interesting albeit a bit
more exciting with the addition of a
certain someone
don't lose your weight the dude
absolutely bodies Tesla in a single hit
and just says next as if it was nothing
I love this guy his nonchalant demeanor
is infectious and it's with this wave of
Awesomeness ride the other captains in
kenpachi's Stead all arriving on the
scene of the down members of ichigo's
party charizukia on the verge of death
but now all with a very good chance of
survival it's an exciting turn of events
thank you
this dude biafia fights has a power
where he can take control of bodies
where he places this symbol on them
regardless of this biakya is ruthlessly
confident severing the connective
tissues to his limbs that get
compromised instantly and then Rukia
gets possessed biaka uses his Bankai and
thus creates more objects than his enemy
can control ending the fight and oh look
he appears behind him that's another
Trope I've recognized in these scenes
for characters to do during fights
however while I don't find the structure
of these fights themselves interesting I
do oftentimes find that I enjoy the
substance of them with regards to the
stories that they are telling how he's
fighting might not be interesting but
why he's fighting in this instance is
sort of telling not from a place of
authority anymore or with a sense of
Duty but for his family for as he puts
it his pride it's a nice indication that
he's developed from the place he was
prior to the soul Society kurotsuchi's
fight on the other hand is a lot more
complicated he's just as callous and
psychotic as ever making quick work of
his opponents along alongside Urdu from
a plot perspective it's again not that
complex but from a back and forth
perspective it goes through the phases
of combat for quite a bit with this
horrific shot of kurosuchi's assistant
ultimately being used as a host to
rebirth the arancas they're fighting
it's gross and morbid however kurosuchi
has a contingency or statistic than
anything we've heard in the story like
something taken straight out of Black
Mirror he drugs the aranca such that his
senses are altered to perceive time and
movements impossibly slowly making his
Death At His Hands slow and agonizing
centuries of done what a hell that must
be to endure similarly to biakyu's fight
the structure is repetitive and
predictable it's the substance however
that provides the interest kubo's fights
have terrific artwork flow character
moments I just wish they had a bit more
variety when it came to the fight's main
beats themselves anyways back at the
Kenpachi fight
the fight rages on and of these three
fights it's this one which is the most
competitive this has a lot of wonderful
moments again lots of Standards shown in
Fanfare but again I find myself asking
how necessary this fight is to the
overall finish to this Arc I think
neutra's backstory is interesting but
the fight itself felt quite bong to me
perhaps it's just because this hueco
Mundo section of the story has a lot of
fighting and at this point it feels less
like a necessary component of the arc
itself and more so a formality if that
makes sense while biakia and kurutsuchi
demonstrated some change from when we
last saw them I don't think it's enough
to justify over 10 chapters to these
guys in the middle of everything it
feels sort of like we're doing these
fights out of an obligation because
there are so many rankers and so we
decided to drag these characters into
the picture to give us a break from the
main cast to add variety and while it
does do that it feels more like a
bandage rather than a solution and so as
a result I think of all the fights that
take place Following okiora being locked
away most of them and felt like they
were biding time for me now some of them
are much more enjoyable than others but
take out this character or that
character on the your anchor side and
not much is lost in terms of story
outside of an obstacle for the heroes to
overcome and that's the last thing a
manga that communicates through fighting
once the fighting shouldn't be an
obstacle that gets in the way of the
story it should be the story and this
particularly feels like it's the case
when chapter 313 comes to an end and
orohime is literally yeated from before
Ichigo and transported back to Eisen in
an instant this does create an obvious
goal to continue the story and it does
broaden it through the introduction of a
threat to karakura town following
Kenpachi reminding Ichigo that that's
his time to protect but to remove
Orihime from them in what feels like a
very cheap fashion just Robs a large
chunk of this Arc and particularly this
section of so much all of this time I
was waiting for okiora to suddenly
reappear and start complicating things
again but instead this sort of feels
like a soft reset of the status quo oh
now it's not uninteresting so don't get
me wrong there are elements I'm still
very excited for I'm just a little
perplexed as to what exactly the point
was of dragging us narratively through
this Dimension and all of these fights
if we're being forced to go right back
to the beginning having not come closer
to achieving our goal the only
difference is that Ichigo and Co are
trapped in this area still looking for
oruhime now that's a good ending I guess
and it builds sufficient tension for the
Final Act of this three-part story but
the way they got to this point felt at
times quite bloated I can appreciate
this middle section in huacomundo
divulging a lot of necessary Exposition
and did Elevate ichigo's abilities which
I'm sure will come in handy with this
upcoming section but given how long it
was I feel like it could have been made
significantly shorter without losing
anything and might have even seen some
benefits by cutting out the fights that
mattered the least with all of that said
I think despite certain characters
interactions and conflicts feeling less
than important or consequential I will
say that I enjoy this world Kubo is
building and I I am still very
interested in the climax he's building
too of these two sections I covered I
think I enjoyed the first part a lot
more but I will say that kubo's art
style and artistic approach to making
manga is so up my alley that even
reading through less than interesting
fight sequences didn't matter much to me
as I could Breeze right on through them
with ease but I can also appreciate that
I might have been singing a very
different tune had I been reading this
week to week so there's that caveat next
week would be the conclusion of this
very long a rankarak my interest is
still intact despite some hiccups I
didn't quite gel with in this section so
I hope I can come and see you all there
for the conclusion to this review series
of the Iran karak next week but until
then I've been toying up Mark and thank
you all so much for watching
foreign
[Music]